all right gang let's get down to
business
oh my god I was gonna but I was worried
about monetizing it all huh stuff oh
well we're recovering a song so don't
worry about it this will not be monetize
hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey and when do you leave a
knee
we got Wendy Lee's a knee back with us
today it's been like over a year at
least
so when do you will probably is seen a
Collider but she has her own YouTube
channel the movie couple channel which
she does with her hubby dusty
how you doing Dustin when I last saw
Wendy she was telling me she's a big
kpop fan keep up and I don't know a lot
of people in California who claim to be
kpop fans except for John and I were
they Suzie it's around here oh I have
not just learn what that is John does
music video reactions at our patreon
page sometimes covers different k-pop
groups ones that Wendy herself is a fan
of but BTS is our main jam here at the
real rejects so I was like if Wendy's
coming by we're definitely gonna cover
some BTS I hit up our dear friend
Natalie door and saying which one should
we cover and she said it has to be this
one fire cuz there they are fire
I'm so excited
big hit they're on a break right now to
tune it up Jones
[Music]
oh it's not to get it'll it I can feel
who is this dark presence
what does that say Youth why are they so
cool I don't know man
well we saw a documentary about them and
we understand what many hard-working
relatable I don't need anyone to explain
you better cool I just but why are you
so cool oh yeah
that's like that I like that oh my god
they're so good they got the best
editors so good
[Laughter]
[Music]
they've been like it's on fire oh my god
they're so cute
[Music]
we're not gonna drop mm-hmm I can learn
these dance cards do it yes you know
there's tutorials setting so many things
on fire like turntables I sorta like
hang out and party with them it'd be
very disciplined partying argue for
exactly 45 minutes oh they're gonna set
everyone on fire so kinetic so visceral
perfection
the production value on all of their
videos I can I also like how they were
showing crowd surfing but in an actual
concert I would actually never hashed it
things on fire Wow we sell a lot of
things on fire get out get out while you
still can
they're so good that was awesome that
was fun wow that is not After Effects
they're like okay BTS is clear the area
[Applause]
dude I gotta say you know even if you're
not really in the kpop I feel like for
the most part then of course not
understanding some Korean language you
can really just listen to that song and
really just enjoy the hell out of it
oh it's totally like cutting edge it's
pop music it's one of the more universal
pop songs that I've heard from BTS were
like I don't feel like I need to know
what they're saying to really feel the
energy and feel even like the choruses
and you know they're just talking about
fire you feel that I love that one might
say that this song itself is this is one
of their more if you will like for
someone who was kind of looking to get
into you know kpop something like this
one you're looking to get into k-pop I'm
not looking I'm saying for those I want
to be your starter pack this is a good
one this is great BTS is a great little
gateway for you to kind of get into
k-pop I feel like they're so since
you're here winning you don't get a
chance to talk about BTS on your channel
what is the thing you love about BTS I
think it's all it's just a visual it's
their group and it's their performances
especially like being a dancer and kind
of seeing all the idols and the way they
dance in the you know they train for
hours on end but BTS does something that
when they dance they're just one unit
and not many groups can move
that and they're one of the guys and
that's why they've crossed over to the
states and they've been able to stay out
here there's a couple of other pop
groups that's tried to do the crossover
in years past and it's been received
well because of kpop fans everywhere but
the mainstream doesn't pick them up but
they are one of the ones when you say
BTS even like a none kpop and be like oh
I've heard of that I have seen them on
this show this show this show exactly
all the late night shows already Awards
you know what's crazy is I feel like the
last one is here for them as American
Awards yeah right
what was the debut was it billboards
firstly their u.s. debut what was crazy
to me was that whatever award show that
they debuted in he forward like lost
their stinking mind and I was like you
guys have something you don't even know
kpop doing like this the whole time like
they're their own perfect like this so
but I'm I love this video it's so great
Jon do the music video guy would you
love about the video I mean I'm
currently moderating a panel you know I
feel like after a certain point you can
say a lot of the same things about the
video portions because they are just so
say to the art and the production values
are crazy and I always feel like I'm
watching a fight scene when I'm watching
them dance because the way they combine
the music which in a song like this is
like hard-hitting it's a banger you know
I really feel the exhilaration and the
energy come off their videos and that's
what I always appreciate the most
because even when there's a like a
complex storyline which this this video
seems very self-contained but it
definitely fit with the theme the dance
moves are incredible and the song itself
has you know a sort of state of the art
pop trap vibe about it you know okay so
I got something I can contribute usually
I just break down their lyrics and half
of it is sarcastic and happen it is very
listen seer but I thought from a visual
sense from a music video being directed
I thought it was cool how it started off
with one person he shakes his hand that
person sets on fire then as you're
watching their like songs caught fire
this whole theme about fire and you're
watching pretty much as each scene
progresses this one flame just sort of
expanding and extending to the point
where the whole building just explodes
and it starts off small and then by
using that energy
and the physical manifestation of fire
the ultimate explosion so I like
watching this element of dude fire
expansion this is about beats yes
because think about it's a bit of like
an underdog anthem they talk about the
people who are on the downsides of life
but then you look at that moment you
know sparking the flame you could argue
that instead of a handshake that was a
mixtape and now the love of BTS is just
spreading until the very end it explodes
all over the world there's got to be a
real Ain Sandman there's gotta be a
remix of every time I say fire truck
just shows up that or no Cassidy effect
fade
don't baby yes make that the dawn okay
do you have a favorite member of bangtan
I I can't have a bias because it changes
all the time okay how do you feel about
Trump joining the group let's look at
the rap monster and j-hope section yeah
are you gonna set everything on fire
turn it up until the dawn is gone that's
cool
live because we're still young who do
you think you are to say otherwise stop
comparing I'm only human
I like that stop come here I'm only
human what why does it have to do with
fire you know we're transitioning to the
outro Wendy thank you for being here
make sure to subscribe to her youtube
channel the movie couple channel and
follow her on Instagram and Twitter
links in description box you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation cuz
subscribe buttons are broken you should
click that notification bell as well
where is it here like there's no there's
no image for the notification bell it
sits below this point to it there sure I
think click on it we have wait this
cannot drown amount of time we've wasted
filming this and also check us on
patreon we got a weekly q and a's do we
do TV show reaction stream along some of
those shows have reaction highlights
included and this guy does music video
reactions go over there he's always
taking requests from people when do you
thank you again see you guys
we did it we set this video on fire
you're fired